no sooner had they knelt
than it began
the sound of booing echoing around the
den before the match against derby
county
and it was definitely the millwall fans
they were the only ones allowed in under
new rules brought in this week
to get home supporters back in the
stands for the first time since
march their response to the player's
action against racism
has been widely condemned in a statement
millwall football club said it was
dismayed and saddened by the booing
adding that the club had been working
tirelessly to prepare for the return of
supporters
and what should have been a positive and
exciting occasion
had been completely overshadowed but the
focus of the incident took a new turn
after a government minister spoke about
the politicization of the movements
to end racial discrimination my personal
view is that
black lives matter capital b
l and m is actually a political movement
that is
uh that is different to what most of us
believe in which is
standing up for racial equality but look
at each
individual can take their own choices
about how they
reflect this and i know a number of
people feel quite strongly and have
taken that approach
his comments have been greeted with
disappointment
i was shocked to be honest it just shows
how privileged he is
it shows white privilege that he can
label it as a political movement and
move on from it
i would say personally it's more of a
social movement that is fighting
equality
and racial injustice but him labeling it
a political movement and not addressing
the racism not addressing what the fans
have done just so it shows that we've
got a long way to go
players began to go down on one knee at
premier league and championship games
when matches resumed in june
and the football association has made it
clear it supports players who wish to do
so
condemning the reaction by millwall
spectators
but as we were filming at the club paul
golding the leader of the far
right group britain first turned up
after recording his own video
in support of the booing fans maximizing
the opportunity it's provided
millwall has said it will ensure it
stays at the forefront of football's
anti-discrimination
efforts but the incident has proved an
unsavory reminder
of the overt racism all too common in
football
in times gone by emma birchley sky news